[Music]
inside of you is
what i don't know there we go you're
listening to inside of you with michael
rosenbaum
my voice is getting deeper ryan
you just went not nice
well i'm holding the ads because you
started to read an ad and then you
decided to do the intro so
yeah ah it's one of those mornings you
wake up really early and you
put on your chewbacca mask and you scare
your dogs and you do what now
i have this chewbacca mask that makes
noises i put it on instagram
for like sex stuff not sex stuff uh i
live alone
uh well i you know you could sit in
front of a mirror naked with a chewbacca
mask and it makes noises
you know the noises so i scared my dogs
this morning that was my uh
that was my morning but it's been a uh
very exciting week uh my band uh sunspin
i know some of you are probably tired of
hearing about it but uh
i gotta promote it i gotta talk about it
a little bit uh it's just uh it's a
great album i'm really proud of it and
uh
we're gonna do a little bit of a contest
so for releasing our new album which is
now out on itunes
and amazon you could also go to
sunspin.com and
get cool merch like coasters stickers
shirts lunch boxes mugs trucker hats and
you could buy the cd
autographed all that [ __ ] but uh what
we're gonna do is
we're gonna do a pretty cool contest
where we give out some goodies for free
um sun spin goodies if you want to learn
more about it go follow us on social
media at
sunspin band and uh to win some free
merch and stuff and
and who knows might we might even do a
zoom or something where we play a couple
songs for you
so uh we're just trying to promote the
album we're not a rocks a big
rock band where we made a really great
album but to get out there into the
public is you know i'm using a platform
such as
my podcast and social to try and get
people to listen to it if it sucked i
wouldn't tell you to listen to it i
wouldn't
mention it but i'm really proud of it i
think it's pretty [ __ ] good
when i say so so take a take a listen
have a listen amazon itunes all that
jazz uh the handles at sunspin band all
over social
and um sunspin.com you can find out you
could book the band
they could they could book a zoom with
us ryan
a wonderful guy definia oh booked us
for a picnic a picnic
where we social distance and play an
hour of music a picnic
and i invited him to play some music of
his own as well so we're going to do
that and you could book the band
we will even fly across the world to see
you but
uh it has to be the right time and uh
when we're available and when
kovit is safe and all that stuff but uh
it's
exciting it's exciting to to have
something you're passionate about
and uh just promoting it and and talking
about it so
i'll leave it at that did you have a
good week not an okay week why is it
okay are you stressed still
you were stressed out the ass last week
i am i think we're both stressed at this
moment
i'm having issues i'm having some issues
i'm doing okay now
this is nice what just sitting here
chatting with another human being
yeah are you going a little cabin
feverish a little bit
remember in the shining did i already do
that uh
you probably where you know he says to
jack nicholson's character
well we had a guy this man um delbert
grady you know
fine man uh good reputation and uh he
came up with here with his family
family man and uh two months in i guess
with the winner and
he couldn't handle it he got what some
people call cabin fever and he
uh he killed his daughters with an axe
and blew his brains out with a shotgun
well i can assure you
i don't remember what jack nicholson
says you know it is par for the course
it is part of the norm right now
anxiety is just like you know we've got
uh you know i've got a lot of my um
sponsors who i cherish because it's
important that i have sponsors on the
show so the show can make money so i
could
pay you and pay bryce and do these
wonderful things and thank you patron
thank you patrons out there for
supporting the show um if you want to
join the wonderful family i always
message you after you join it's um
patreon.com
inside of you patreon.com inside of you
it's a really wonderful close in their
family but they've helped me through
this
because you know i'm on different meds
right now trying to
deal with my anxiety and i haven't
always been one to get on meds but
in fact most of my life i haven't been
on and this is something that
is just trying to make me more even
keeled so i don't
i feel like anxious ryan i feel like uh
i'm fine and i use that term loosely but
i don't want anybody to worry about me
i'm not worried i have a great therapist
and i'm just trying to i have that
feeling where imagine someone's grabbing
your shirt just kind of pulling you a
little bit
and you're like hey i just i want to
relax but it's just pulling you a little
bit like i'm anxious i have to do this
i have to do that i can't get it done
you know uh it's almost like you're too
anxious to get things done
that's true you know what i mean yeah
you know what i mean
how do you deal with it uh not well i
mean i
don't yeah but i know what you mean like
you sort of you're so anxious about
doing everything that you just do
nothing because you're worried about
i don't have time to do all of the
things so i just got to sit here and not
do anything
wow that was uh articulated well because
i
understood you completely maybe because
it's my
uh my mind sometimes a run helps
sometimes
the guitar session helps but then it's
these days it's hard to to fully get rid
of all of it
i found yeah and the more you have on
your plate the more stress the more you
know
but uh you know look it's good to be
busy i
i again gratitudes man i always say i
got a roof over my head i got two great
dogs um you know the stress of my old
dog is probably kicking in
into my psyche a little bit but uh you
know i'm blessed we're all blessed in
in some way you gotta find something
special
in everything we do and and uh this i'm
very uh
grateful for this podcast i'm grateful
that the the people who do listen
my listeners uh tune in and and want to
hear what i have to say and want to hear
what the guests have to say
would i love it if uh you know the big
guests that get tons of numbers
uh would bleed over and people would
continue to listen that
like that particular guest sure but i
can't control things ryan
we can't control things so we have to
let them go like hey this is what it is
be grateful move on enjoy it while it
lasts
be present be in the moment so i urge
you to try and be in the moment take a
walk
um not you the proverbial you i am not
not exactly
yeah [ __ ] man [ __ ] uh thank you for
listening to the podcast guys
uh you know please write a review it
helps more than anything
uh what are the uh handles oh they're uh
inside of you pod on twitter
inside of your podcast on instagram
facebook youtube.com
insidew with michael rosenbaum and
they're right here in front of me so you
can see them
if you're watching the video and uh if
you're listening i also urge you to
while you're listening play the youtube
you know we get a view for that
and vice versa yeah um i'm excited about
this guest because
i was a big walking dead fan he's got a
big following and
i didn't know him at all some of the
guests i don't know at all and uh
it worked out perfectly i thought there
was a steady flow of conversation
conversing and uh michael cudlitz is a
great guy he's got a new series
called clarice uh it's you know
obviously silence of the lambs and um
it's really interesting i think he plays
a detective and he talked a lot about
walking dead about conventions about
um all the stuff so if you're a fan
you're gonna love it but i i urge you to
stick around for other episodes and
maybe just maybe you'll uh
you'll like the show and you'll want to
stick around and tell your friends and
that's it's all about word of mouth
every actor and their mother
started a podcast during this epidemic
pandemic
and i've had this podcast for two and a
half years now so i have been here
done that so i urge you to uh follow us
on
all these things and you know uh i think
we should probably get into
our uh wonderful guest shouldn't we
let's do it let's get into michael
cudlitz it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
you're in uh montreal toronto where are
you toronto
toronto you see me pretty good huh yeah
it's good
it's dude it's like to be working right
now is insane
and we had a really great first half and
nobody got sick and this is for clarice
yeah dude i'm so pumped man i'm a huge
silence of the lambs fan
i am like you know i'm one of those guys
that like watch movies and memorize
lines and then give impressions to
people and they're like god this guy
doesn't have a life
you're not that guy but i'm that guy
michael i'm that guy
clarice six foot four 120 pounds
louis friend you know i remember all
that [ __ ] like
uh what was the thing where he goes oh
agent sterling
you think you can dissect me with your
blow little tool you're so ambitious
aren't you
but you know what you look like with
your good bag and your cheap shoes
you look like a rogue a wild [ __ ]
hustling the road with a little taste
the magicians gave me lynn pho bone but
you're really not one more generation
from pure white trash are you asians
telling
that actually you so desperately tried
to share i knew the whole thing i'm a
loser michael
you don't do that do you you don't
memorize lines no
i do uh i i have enough trouble
memorizing my
yeah me too by the way it's been one of
those days right now that i got in i'm
so out of it today
that i actually try to put my seatbelt
on in my chair here
yeah there's no reason for that you're
afraid you're gonna fall out i'm afraid
this is gonna be such an intense
uh an interview that uh so
look i've always enjoyed your work man i
you know it's a treat to have you on and
like
you know you see you in southland and
you see in in all these
i mean you have the thing is with your
resume you're one of those guys
you're like a real man i i strive to be
a real man michael
but you build [ __ ] i'm striving to be a
real man
dude you build [ __ ] you're from new
jersey
i mean these are real man essentials but
no you've done so much work like i look
like the the list of work like even one
episode one episode one was
you just seem like the guy who just
wants to be on set wants to work this is
what you love am i am i wrong there
i used to joke it was a time when i was
doing a lot of guest spots
and um i'm going to change my glasses
do it i guess i got something out of it
this is now time while michael cudlitz
changes his glasses
are those those look good too is those
the same these are the same
yeah i i actually bought new glasses
here before i left and i
got them just before i ran back home for
six days
right and i'm pretty sure i left them at
home well you could have somebody
send them and then sanitize your hands
yeah i feel like just
they're like they're cheap they're so
i'll probably just get another pair here
and it'll
come in two weeks well i want to get
back to what you were saying about those
roles but also are you the kind of guy
that makes a lot of money now
because you've worked your ass off and
you deserve it and you've done all this
stuff but do you still like
cheap things because i still love deals
yeah i don't i don't even
yeah yeah i live pretty frugally
um yeah
why is that why is that just because i
don't know i mean i grew up in new
jersey
pretty blue collar you know my folks
each had two jobs growing up and
you know i worked my way through school
doing construction um
did construction as my day gig when i
was trying to get my career going and
i don't know i guess i just uh you know
i saw a lot of people
as i'm sure you you know you've been
doing this a while we know we have
friends that are incredibly incredibly
talented
that just stop working one day and it's
not because they choose to
it's because they just stop working and
i don't know what the math is on it but
i'm very aware that there's potentially
a shelf life
on all of this yeah um
so i i just try to focus on the work and
you know i've been really really
fortunate
um started directing a couple years ago
and you know that's insane to me that
they would even give me a chance with
you know with the way that uh there's
there's so many great
directors that are not working um
so to come into it knew
you know in you know my 50s
and just sort of be like all right you
know they're giving me a chance
um which is crazy to me so i i just sort
of
feel real blessed to
be doing this still and people still
want to
watch well i you know it's funny well
you're incredibly humble but you know
you look at the imdb and you look at all
these things
and you're like holy [ __ ] ryan my
engineer editor friend he was sitting
there and going god this guy's done it
all
i mean i mean this guy was building like
doing construction on beverly hills
90210 then was on 24 and lost and
first of all when you're working on
beverly hills 90210 did you ever see the
stars like the big stars and how old
were you when that happened
i was uh i was out of college so i was
in
27 87 90. i was probably 25.
did you see dylan and those guys i'm
friends with all those guys now i mean i
just talked i missed i'm just missed
jason he was up here shooting private
eyes
and because of the cove and stuff we
weren't able to actually
um hook up and we were gonna we're gonna
at one point we said all right before
you get out of town we're gonna we're
gonna
go grab a coffee and take a walk and you
know be outside and socially distanced
and but
be able to to hang out and it wound up
not happening cause my work schedule up
here got so insane but
um i've i've loosely kept in touch with
with everyone else a little more with
jason i was very close friends with
luke our kids uh together
um uh the ladies i see in passing
uh every once in a while um gabrielle is
in my neighborhood and
we're friends um
uh that's great i just spoke to him
recently
i can't keep in touch with all those
guys basically i mean when you you see a
guy your colleague your peer like
somebody like and i i don't even
know we're gonna go there but you know
after luke's passing it's so sudden
and you're like i mean to me that just
puts everything in perspective and makes
you think like hey
it really is and these these thoughts
are sort of ephemeral like i wish
you think like that i mean obviously you
can't dwell on things but
to know that hey like that it's over
like that it is over so what do we do we
gotta live every day and we gotta
and you think those things and then you
forget that you kind of go back to your
same [ __ ] right we all do that
it's like new year's resolution it's
like oh i'm gonna work out i'm gonna
i'm gonna not masturbate as much and i i
don't know why i went there
but you know what i'm saying so uh i
mean how do you approach those things
when you see a colleague or a friend
like that how do you deal with that
stuff are you pretty
like solid like in terms of like
upbringing and how you deal with
problems because i'm kind of all over
the place and i'm
i'm a man i think i'm kind of all over
the place too you know
sometimes different parts of your life
come into focus in different ways
and um that was huge you know the loop
thing and i i don't i don't
uh i'm perfectly fine talking about this
now
um but at the time i wasn't uh
i wasn't talking about um my friendship
with him and what an amazing person he
was because there were a lot of people
who
um were
taking advantage of that um as her time
to get in the press and that sounds
shitty
but i saw it and i'm not talking about
his close friends there are close
friends out there it is that
that were much closer than me yeah that
loved that man and and you know gave
wonderful tributes so i'm not talking
about that at all
but because i wasn't that close to him
um
i was very aware that this this is
you know my relationship with him with
luke was was very close and very
personal
and wasn't in the press so why should my
reaction to his
passing be in the press yeah
if for no other reason than to put me in
the press yeah that
just seemed kind of [ __ ] up to me so i
didn't i didn't do any of that so i
haven't really talked about
um his passing and
uh for me it was a huge
a huge wake-up call because we we we're
you know we're close in age i'm older
which just even makes more like [ __ ]
yeah um but he passed from the same
thing that my mother-in-law
had just passed from two years ago uh so
like
six months uh or eight months prior to
his passing i don't know i get that um
um not shortly after my mother-in-law
passed
luke passed um and it was the same exact
thing and i was just like
like that that's not that's supposed to
happen to people who are much much older
um
and you know the fact that it did happen
was as you said a huge wake-up call and
you sort of just go
yeah you need to you need to
you need to have your short-term goals
as long as your long-term as well as
your long term goals if you only have
long term goals
you might not live to see them that's
right
no matter how you're working so you know
the the i don't know who said this but
there's a quote that says you know life
is what happens
while you're waiting for your life to
begin
um and a lot of people do that they're
like oh oh i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna
i'm gonna
and you can't i'm gonna for the rest of
your life
because you are you know you have to
sort of live
at least partially where you are right
now and enjoy that time
uh otherwise you're going to miss it wow
i love
you you can't i'm gonna for the rest of
your life you're never gonna do it i
mean it's so it's it's really true it's
you know again i'm gonna as long as you
are you know that's right
right right there is stuff going on now
absolutely have the long-term goals as
well
yeah i just feel like uh i go outside
sometimes and i just i force myself i'm
like why can't you just like look up at
the sky and the trees i'm like because
they're there they'll always be there
they're [ __ ] trees they're
it's a sky and then you're like that's
not that's 911.
that's the twin towers i mean i grew up
in new york i grew up in new jersey
sorry born in new york grew up in new
jersey been in and out of new york
city my whole youth uh and as an adult
and never did
you know never did the world trade
center never went up into the world
trade center just to see the view the
observation
never did uh stash for liberty never did
uh
empire state building because in your
mind that's always there i can always go
do that tourists do that
and i regret that so now i kind of
i've been real fortunate with with
what's been happening in my career
lately that i've been able to travel the
world a lot and i
i try to go see all the wonderful
dumb you know dumb tourist stuff that i
can
like the cnn community louis you go see
the arch well that toronto the cnn thing
right cnn
exactly yeah you better be up there i'm
actually going out there
if it's open back up after the after my
my
current quarantine is over uh if they're
doing any kind of social distance thing
there but i'm gonna i'm gonna do that
before i get out of here
yeah i i could just see that i think
that's important to do things that you
don't
i i just i do that all the time i just
procrastinate and i just you get caught
up in your world you know my therapist
always said
michael your inbox is never going to be
empty
it's never going to be empty you've got
to just like
let it go let things go do things be
present and
i've definitely gotten better i've
definitely gotten better i think this
podcast doing this has forced me to
be present to have real conversations
and i think it's a blessing in disguise
because i didn't even really want to do
this
and then i started being vulnerable and
like real and then all of a sudden
people are writing letters and i'm like
really this helps you i didn't how am i
how am i helping you me
it's impossible it's got to be ryan my
engineer so
um yeah i i i like what you said and um
i'm going to quote it repeatedly after i
memorized it i have to take the time to
memorize it
well don't do it in anthony hopkins
voice yeah yeah oh yes i will
never say you're going to just do a job
tomorrow means not not living for today
and then do this after yeah at the same
time we did the
we did the thing oh man i love that you
know i know you auditioned for band of
brothers
and you got it and it you know you just
changed your life i also tested for it
with tom hanks
and i remember the building where i
walked in and yeah you're probably there
that day when
when spielberg when there were all the
people who were who had
sort of at the beginning of their career
then there were always sort of there was
eight or nine superstars that were
in there and we were all kind of going
well we're not gonna ever get hired
yeah i i you know what i remember going
in there and uh
the lantana building yeah was that it i
remember it was just like this little
room you went into a room and then there
was another
room to the right right you go in and
tom hanks was like get in here
and he just sat there and we read and
then i came back and he was mixing and
matching and
he got you ready because he goes how do
you feel i feel good he was just so
sweet and
what what do you remember about the
process because at this point
you really were still at cal institute
right yeah i got
i just gotten out that was to
1999.99 yeah uh
because we sh we started i get well
actually it was probably 1998. so you
were like 29
and then 30.
[Music]
i was 35 when i did it oh wow you look a
lot younger
yeah yeah yeah that's been a blessing
yeah
awkward times but a blessing um i
remember
like all of it um and it was insane i
was doing
uh i was working on sitcom at the time
doing just a day gig
and they they let me out in the morning
to go do it
um because they knew what it was but
they were like if anything else comes up
with this rest of this week for it you
can't so i let them know that
and because we're filming like taped on
a
thursday and a friday and
so you know meg was like yeah i think if
it goes any further
it's not you know you're not gonna hear
anything for a good couple of weeks
you know so we the first thing was
happened like we went in and then they
did as you're saying that mix and match
part of it and there may have been it
may have come back twice i may have
may have come back a second time to see
meg because they read us all for the
same two or three parts
right initially that were not the roles
that we were going to play they were
just stuff that was more flushed out i
know if you remember
uh some of the stuff we read was like
was stuff that was not in the
in the show it was stuff like back in
town uh it was in toccoa
before they left they went overseas and
it was in real time and it wasn't just
training they had like
it was kind of what they did in the
pacific it was some of the a slice of
life
at home and then the slice of life of
trying right
there they're playing around i think
with that early on and i think they
realize they just need to do just
just the men in training with each other
and build that relationship
but i remember we went in and uh
i read i think the compton stuff the
buck compton stuff was the stuff
because it was it was a nice scene in a
big monologue
um so you're kind of like they were like
just play with it right
because we weren't auditioning for buck
content right you know everybody was
reading the same two
same thing right and uh and then when we
came back that's when we got the
different material
and he started splitting us up and
mixing and matching and you know
certain roles there were some you can't
even see with the guys the way they
looked like at the time you know
sort of you know dark hair and lean and
shorter
and there was like four or five guys
that were almost interchangeable
uh in the audition process and then
there were some guys who were definitely
you know your bucks and your bulls and
you know and those guys that were
iconically described as
or were described iconically as as
certain sizes
and you know james maddio who played
perkane who's
much much smaller than me i love you
jimmy it's not an insult
um you just you just are um
there's no way he would have been hired
to play bull or buck
um and and vice versa there's no way i
would have been hired to
play perconti but there were uh it was a
chunk in the middle that
that sort of was interchangeable i think
those guys were kind of slugging it out
for
you know the same or different roles in
the same grouping
right um and then i remember when we all
got back
and we got called in for our our mix and
match uh
uh call back how nervous were you by the
way
uh pretty nervous you know but but
probably not as nervous as i should have
been because i'm
so stupid i didn't really know what it
you know we didn't really know what it
was
yet we knew you know it was tom hanks
and steven spielberg so initially i was
enough with something like this you're
kind of like this is gonna be a career
changer
like you know you don't care and i say
this with all respect because
it comes back around i didn't give a
[ __ ] about these guys
like in the sense of like some sort of
historical context or the families or
some legacy
i was like [ __ ] this i'm gonna [ __ ]
work with tom hanks and steven spielberg
because you're not you're not seeing the
whole project in this context
um once we we went through
uh we paired up mixed and mashed and
stephen was actually at the final
one filming uh an old vhs or
probably whatever the state of the art
thing was at the time
and he's like you know doing handheld
stuff and kind of moving around us and
everything and
um we came in and there was a bunch of
guys there
who were auditioning who were stars and
then there was a bunch of us who were
not
yeah and that they obviously made a
very specific choice to go with people
who were not associated with any other
things necessarily in their career
except for david schwimmer
and and choose sort of no-name
guys to to become these guys so people
would know
them as that not go oh there's there's
you know whoever played that role
why don't they do that more sorry to
interject but why don't they to me
they do it in horror movies right they
do in horror movies because no one gives
a [ __ ] if it's scary i'll watch it i
don't care who the [ __ ] in it
but they have to put these huge budgeted
movies that all go to the big actors no
one cares
make a comedy with funny people i don't
give a [ __ ] if they're not i mean
kristin wig's amazing but you know if
it's a funny script and you
find some no names you're going to save
a [ __ ] ton of money and make a funny
movie
nobody really cares they have to put
like something just happened like i got
there was a roll
and they gave it to someone huge
and i'm like why you didn't need that
person
you got your money i'll do it for 5 000
cents
i've had things come to me where i'm
like what are you doing
why no i mean like thank you i
appreciate the offer
um go hire somebody else and pay them
really well
uh like you know i don't i i don't have
time for this
i don't i mean it's not that i don't
need it i mean i you know i
need to keep working we all do but there
there are roles that i look at and there
people come to me sometimes and offer
them and they're just offers
and they're like hey we want you i'm
like i don't
this is not it's not gonna help my
career i'm not gonna really make
you know that much money on it but it
will help someone else's career yeah
like it'll change someone else's life
today's program is brought to you by
athletic greens the most comprehensive
daily nutritional beverage i have ever
tried and that
is a fact this is how easy it is
all your vitamins and nutrients i mean
there's so many in these packets that
they give you
and uh you know they have a variety of
whether you want single packets if
you're on the road
make it easier we don't have a lot of
time for things in this day and age
right
ryan we want things now done quickly you
can just pour a glass of water
dump the contents in give it a little
mixy mix and it tastes good
and that's important to me and i drink a
whole glass of this stuff and i'm
telling you
i feel freaking so much better
than i normally do when i wake up and i
go for the peanut butter
and i you know this is what you need you
need athletic greens you want to get
going you want to change your life you
want to uh
people think about exercising and diet i
i truly believe in athletic greens
their daily all-in-one superfood powder
is your nutritional essential
it is by far the easiest and most
delicious nutritional habit
that you can add to your health routine
today while avoiding the need to take
multiple pills
or add complex routines they simplify
the logistics of getting
optimal nutrition on a daily basis by
giving you
one thing with all the best things
that really sums it up for me one thing
you take
you pour it in a glass of water and you
have all the things that you actually
need ryan why don't you tell us what's
in one of these tasty scoops of athletic
greens
uh 75 vitamins minerals and whole
food-sourced ingredients including a
multivitamin multimineral
probiotic greens superfood blend and
more
that all work together to fill the
nutritional gaps in your diet
increase energy and focus aid with
digestion and supports a healthy immune
system and without the need to take
multiple products right now athletic
greens is doubling down on supporting
your immune system during the winter
months
they're offering my audience a free
one-year supply of vitamin d and five
free travel packs
with your first purchase if you visit my
link today you'll basically
never have to buy vitamin d again so
whether you're looking for peak
performance
or better health covering your bases
with athletic greens makes investing in
your energy
immunity and gut health each day
simple tasty and efficient
simply visit athleticgreens.com
y o u and join health experts
athletes and health conscious go-getters
around the world who make a daily
commitment to their health
every day make a commitment to your
health again simply visit
athleticgreens.com
y-o-u and get your free year supply of
vitamin d and five free travel packs
today inside of you is brought to you by
geico if you don't have geico i don't
know what kind of insurance you guys
have but
uh uh geico makes it so damn
easy for you folks uh you know everybody
knows geico
and they have these bundling policies
ryan so if you rent or own your home
it's the hardest thing to do is pay your
mortgage
i've talked about this and then you got
to go
pay somebody else for your auto policy
your home policy got all these policies
so what do you do you go to geico geico
makes it easy
it's a bundling policy it's all in one
you don't have to go to these other
people and it's just one check or one
card or whatever you however you pay
your insurance company it's it's very
simple it's geico easy even a rosenbaum
can do it
you go to geico.com get a quote
see how much you could save it's really
geico easy visit
geico.com today that's geiko
geico even a rosenbaum can do it
inside of you is brought to you by
capsule guys
i don't know about you but i i effing
hate to go to the pharmacy
it you know you don't think it's a it's
an inconvenience because you're like oh
it's the pharmacy
but then it's the post office it's the
grocery store it's all these things
why not make life easy and capsule
does that my life is becoming so much
easier
with companies like this capsule's a new
kind of pharmacy that hand delivers your
prescription the same day for free
and ryan tell them how it works it's so
simple uh to start visit capsule.com it
only takes 15 seconds to sign up when
your prescription is ready capsule will
text you to schedule
free delivery at a time you choose then
a capsule courier hand delivers your
medication to your door
straight from the pharmacy in a
tamper-proof package
it's totally secure and if you have any
questions you can call text or email
with an expert pharmacist
it's that simple no more waiting in line
no more driving to the pharmacy no more
forgetting refills best of all
even though it's a way better experience
capsule doesn't cost any more
than your old pharmacy capsule accepts
all major insurance and is currently
available in new york city and
surrounding tri-state areas
austin boston chicago the twin cities
and la and other cities are coming
very soon and to sign up as ryan said
before you just go to capsule.com it
takes 15 seconds
and you get your prescription hand
delivered today for free
that's capsule.com
but getting back to that other the the
story with the man yeah
uh brothers the um you know when it was
all
said and done and then we got the
scripts
that's when you realize holy [ __ ]
this is based on a real book and these
are the men
and these are the interviews and i can
contact the family and i can contact
people who knew him and you know i you
know as i was told early on my guy had
passed so i was talking to all his
friends
talking to one of his friends one day
and he's like why don't you call him and
ask him this
and i was like excuse me
he's like why don't you why have you
talked to bull yet
and i'm like well
one of us is wrong here and i don't want
to make you nervous
but i was told that he passed away
and they're like when did he pass away i
said well i was told
he passed away about six months ago oh
and
then i'm told well i talked to him two
weeks ago
so i don't think your information is
correct what
so i go back of course i'm like from
freaking out i just got chills i got
look at this the hair on my arms because
i thought like oh god he's going to be
emotional it's like i didn't know my
buddy died and he's alive
yeah yeah no no that's what i was put in
the middle of i'm like oh uh
okay my mind is like how the
[ __ ] do i figure this out so then i'm
like really
you know sort of in a bind and a loss
and a weird place like i called
production i called tom's company
and i'm like um i just found this out
and i don't think i'm the one who should
pursue this i think you guys should
make the initial phone call and they
were like
yes because we'd also like to go
interview him
because we did not know right um
and then we found him good work michael
good work solid work
yeah thanks for finding out he's alive
we're a huge production and we couldn't
figure that [ __ ] out but i'm glad you
called his friend
yep and then uh you know and then
ultimately uh
i had to you know i had to make reach
out and call him and that was
possibly the most surreal
uh experience
i literally i was so nervous i i think i
rehearsed
picking up the phone and like what i was
going to say first because i was like
how do you
how do you what's your opener on that i
am the guy who's going to play you in
the movie
well i mean what the movie you don't
even really know about because
you were dead up until 10 minutes ago um
how did you [ __ ] start that journey
as a kid you know it's i i i
i probably the most adult thing i was
forced to do uh as a
as a kid you know as a kid i was a 35
year old man
a kid uh as far as a kid into a you know
an 80
83 year old world war ii vet
um so he uh he was wonderful
um and very short in his answers in our
first
encounter uh was there a lot of blood
yep
[Music]
what are the opening questions i've
talked about this a million times i
don't
but hasn't talked about it at all that's
the amazing thing and it's a person who
has a personality
who doesn't really talk wow so
he's not really communicative even when
he does know you
so here's this kid who's gonna play him
in the movie
uh so you can imagine how that went he's
like how are you sir
good all right
okay uh so i'm uh
talking to my dad and in stephen
ambrose's book
we're turning into a mini series have
you heard anything about that
a little
oh my god this goes on for probably
10 or 15 minutes and it's excruciatingly
for me
um i'm sure he's fine he's just
answering the questions and then
uh and then i i finish up and i'm like
okay you know what um
i'm gonna you know just let this go for
now and uh
i'm gonna mind if i talk to your wife uh
and say goodbye and thank her because i
talked to her first for a minute he said
sure
well i wound up talking to her for about
an hour and a half long
and and if you want to get to know
somebody talk to somebody that
know that loves and knows them because
we
are we are who we sort of uh
we talk about ourselves in in in sort of
ways that we want people to perceive us
but if you want to know how you're
really perceived in the world talk to
somebody else
because they're looking at you go
through it so i got more
more of what i did you know and how i
portrayed bull uh
denver was was based on most of the
information i got from
from bureau wow and then months later
and into it as
and as as the project evolved and as it
finally
was released um
uh denver and his family became very
close with our family
and uh he opened up
and we'd have great conversations and uh
it was
it was possibly one of the most
sort of amazing work-related thing that
has ever happened to me and i never will
i don't i don't expect anything to ever
top
the sort of experience so far as
creative work uh
you know extended family and personal
uh way that this project has affected
well
if you don't mind if you don't mind i'd
like to call him and talk to him
well now i have some bad news for you
all right what are you gonna say can you
just say say the right thing
cheap asked a number of years ago he did
did they call they call you and tell you
was that
did jira call you um no actually
uh how was it it's it's kind of terrible
um
in the sense of uh the kid his kids
passed before him they outlived their
children
awful um and
and then vera passed you're a past then
denver pat no denver yeah very fast then
denver passed and
then the sun passed the daughter dear
denver
oh man you know my mom it was uh
it was amazing to have you know be able
to document everything and it was
amazing to sort of
uh become part of that family's family
because they were certainly part of ours
well it's cool because you
also did the event you do so much but
you did the return to hardwick
that's coming out on pbs uh you know so
check that out it's about the bombers of
world war ii
and you you're the narrator so i mean
you know
it's probably for you nice because since
band of brothers you haven't done many
maybe military kind of
roles right yeah that was they actually
reached out to me to do
um to do a small blurb in the beginning
michael sellers who's one of the
grandchildren of
one of the airmen and
a friend of a friend reached out and
said hey
buddy's got this uh uh reunion group
you know and they they keep in touch
with the the men and the families and
that's like oh my gosh that's that's
exactly like
what the bander brothers guys do
whatever they need yes and like well no
we're going to texas no no whatever you
need
so we did a couple recordings and then
he said the amount would you want to do
more i said i'll do whatever you want me
to do because i know
what this is it's documenting the legacy
of those men and
you know not every every bomber group
not every uh squadron not every platoon
has a band of brothers made for them
although it is representational of all
of them
they don't get to tell their stories in
such an amazing way
um and i felt very fortunate for the men
of easy company that we were able to do
that for them
and anyone who's doing any kind of
effort to document
and save that for future generations um
i'm on board this is that's like a
no-brainer that's awesome hold on
you know my grandmother just tried to
call me and it [ __ ] up the whole thing
oh you gotta call grandma no i just
gotta like get you back for some reason
hold on i'm gonna press zoom here
there it is you're back you're back just
wanna make sure you're panned yeah
and she keeps she keeps calling too why
won't you
answer your phone cause she [ __ ]
thinks she's getting
disconnected i'm on the phone so you
can't
answer for your grandmother it was a doc
yeah
my dad when my dad calls my dad had his
heart valve replaced uh
it'll be four years this next coming
summer
and the phone rings i pick it up no
matter what i'm doing if i have my phone
with me
yeah if i if i don't need to be if i
can't be interrupted i don't take my
phone with me but
i've been directing i've been sort of
talking to the crew and you know
a couple years ago when it first
happened and my phone rang i left
it was my dad i was like hang on a
second all right michael you know what
don't make me feel like
wait a minute don't make me feel like
[ __ ] michael cause now i didn't answer
my girl you know i answered my dad
i answer him all the time don't you
don't have to answer
i do mostly answer her i i mostly do
answer her
because she's my favorite person on the
planet in fact i want to interview on
the podcast because
she said i'm telling you i've never been
loved that's one of those what i should
have could is
no no i am i am i'm just she doesn't
know how to do zoom and she's like
isolating in in florida so i have to
figure that out she's getting vaccinated
tomorrow
but i'm going to do it because i've had
her on the podcast before like in the
intros
but she's so cute and i've never been
unconditionally loved by someone
like she loves me and when she tells me
she
i try to call her out on it like i'll
say something like she goes because i
i mikey i love you so much i go yeah
you're old you're saying this because
you're old she goes no
i lit michael i've never met anyone i've
never known anyone like you
in my entire life and i go i don't know
what that means what is it
i'm saying that i love you and i go oh
you say that to me no
i say this to you i know all everybody
in my family this is for you
i'm telling you and she and i have that
connection you know so it is nice and
i do pick up where where's she where's
she from she lives in florida
she's uh you know she's from new york
she's from the bronx originally but
the bronx is okay yeah the way you're
talking he's describing my aunt reba
aunt reeve i love i love it i love it
google
google are you hey are you are you a
giants fan or jets fans say giants
you're jets
i don't see it either because when i
moved to new jersey i was like
you know what [ __ ] all you guys you're
all playing in new jersey
i don't give a [ __ ] and neither one of
you is calling yourselves
the new jersey jets or giants that
you're playing here
what a dick i love it hey all right so
look you got me look you were southland
you got a critic critics choice award
you did walking dead you got this show
clarice
you you've done it you're by the way
you're still pretty damn young
and you've done all these great things
um what is it
that you want to do like we talk about
this is what i'm gonna do
do you see yourself ever retiring from
acting or do you want to be one of those
martin sheen guys doing you know
not yeah i don't i don't see retiring
because i love telling stories too much
um but i definitely see myself slowing
down
you know um there's gonna be a time
where i'm i'm not gonna be able to
to do uh network television um
the pace of it is is all concerned
yeah um and so i'll direct it
you know but i don't know if you know
probably you know 10 years from now if
i'm going to want to
do the grind of a 22-episode
show and all the work that's required to
do it correctly
um and well are you good at memorizing
lines by the way
it it depends what depends on the
project um
sometimes it's it's brutal because
they're not written well
and sometimes it's like
easy when they are written well so it's
it's uh
it's about connecting with the character
and the material and
how it's written um i love
the back and forth the exposition stuff
gun sometimes can be a grind um although
i have to say on on
this show since we it is serialized
uh it's it's been wonderful there's just
been
just really incredible dynamic scenes
between characters which for me that's
the easiest stuff to get
um it's just when it's just the
wholesale bulk like
you know blah blah blah it's just like
anybody could any character could
[ __ ] say it because all it's doing is
giving you information
that's when it gets to be a pain in the
ass i used to say things like you know
hey
uh can you give this to the chloe
character
it's more exposition and like rosenbaum
you just don't want to memorize it i'm
like absolutely and i'm second on the
call sheet so
can we make this happen no i wouldn't do
that i would do that i wouldn't yeah i
don't want
i don't want i don't want to do all the
exposures no although in my job right
now
i do a lot of exposition because i'm the
leader of the team but
it's it's it's there's a purpose it's
not it's not your typical
um exposition it's actually
incredibly it's it's i told the writers
of this it's the best pilot i've ever
read wow and the scripts have been
fantastic
it's it's that's you know my i showed it
to my wife run everything by my wife and
when she's read it she's like you have
to do this
you know i was like i think i'm gonna do
like you know am i talking myself into
this but i
like i feel like this is like terrific
and she's like
but it's network like yeah but it
doesn't read like network
like read this tell me if i'm crazy and
she read it and she's like you have to
do this
so is she someone who will a does she
see everything you do
b does she ever say is she always just
like you were great great job honey
great job or she ever liked she just
doesn't say anything like she'll tell
you the truth like ah you're okay
yeah she'll she'll um she'll tell me
when it's not
when it's out there you know or and it's
usually it's you know i've been very
fortunate again i i've been doing this a
minute um
there's for television i think
i think it would be it would be really
hard for me to be like just awful
because awful to me is like a complete
you know i don't know it's just it's
literally not understanding the scene at
all
not there's so many there's so many
things that if you commit to
you can pull yourself out of awful even
if you make the wrong choice
if you've committed to a choice people
are going to go oh that wasn't what i
would do but
yeah you were bad you weren't awful yeah
it's hard
it's very hard to be really awful it is
um
it really is i mean if you're if you're
if you are present
and you are you know trying to tell a
good story and trying to communicate
with your other
your other actors um but she you know i
know
there's times where she's like you know
oh my gosh i was like
wasn't it you know i didn't see you at
all you know i was able to completely
enjoy that
and there are times where she's like
well you did your job you kind of you
did your job
i did my job and that haunts you that
just upsets the [ __ ] out of you and
you're like what do you mean
i did my job there you go oh man i do
the same thing to her
you know like with with her she's a
writer now and i do the same thing with
her and i'm like you know you you're
like you're better than this you know
why are you why are you being so
reserved and she'll be like no you're
right so i think uh
i think we push each other in good ways
that's helpful together for
been together in 30 34
34 years now that's incredible in this
business
yeah good for you good for her yeah
well as i said she's perfect except
obviously she's an idiot
that was so chris farley i'm not good
you know what's funny we were talking
about
it's like well she's with the wrong guy
here let's be honest
well i love the fish out there and this
is what she chose
oh my god you're right
whatever you gotta live with your
choices
inside of you is brought to you by
relief band
i don't know about you guys but if i'm
on a boat uh i get nausea
yep i get nauseous yep is that the right
way to say it i do i get nauseous
there's certain things that make me
nauseous i get a little lightheaded i
get whatever
you know being nauseous it's
uncomfortable you know you can't focus
you feel like you're going to throw up
it's like you know there's nothing worse
than talking to someone and going uh-huh
you know people who deal with i'm sure
people who deal with migraines all the
time
and you know you know time of the month
stuff
and whatever we deal with in life folks
you know it's just crap that we have to
deal with that but now we don't have to
deal with it
with relief band because they've created
something that really helps
us folks that have these issues relief
ban is the number one
fda cleared anti-nausea wristband that
has been clinically
proven to quickly relieve and
effectively prevent nausea
and vomiting associated with motion
sickness anxiety
migraine hangover morning sickness
chemotherapy
so much more the product is 100 drug
free non-drowsy
and provides all-natural relief with
zero
side effects for as long as needed how
it works
is relief band stimulates a nerve in the
wrist
that travels to the part of the brain
that controls nausea
then it blocks the signal your brain is
sending to your stomach telling you that
you are
sick relief bands the only
over-the-counter wearable device
that has been used in hospitals in
oncology clinics to treat nausea
and vomiting and you know something
i have a van don't ask me why but you
know
when someone else is driving i'm in the
back turns around the hills or whatever
you get nauseous sometimes you're on a
flight you go to an amusement park
these are things that you don't think
like i don't get nauseous that often oh
really
but you do and uh that's why i really
think relief band is
is a wonder is a wonder ensure nazi is
never the reason to miss out on one of
life's
important moments right now relief ban
has an exclusive offer just for inside
of you listeners
if you go to reliefband.com and use the
promo code inside you'll receive
20 off plus free shipping and no
questions
asked 30-day money-back guarantee it's
as simple as that
so head to r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d that's
reliefband.com
and use our promo code inside for 20
off inside of you is brought to you by
better help
folks we all need help i don't care who
you are
we talk about this on the podcast we all
need to talk to someone sometimes
someone who is objective someone who
could
help you through dark thoughts dark days
better help is there better help has
helped so many people around the world
and um you know during these troubled
times and
it's not just covid it's not just uh
it's
you know people say oh this is you know
it's situational it's not situational
your life is not situational it's
you're gonna have things arise all the
time
whether it's uh you know death or uh
you know uh other mental health issues
such as anxiety depression
better help is there with online
counseling it's private it's secure
uh if you're embarrassed which i hope
you're not but you want to talk to
someone you could talk to someone now
and no one has to know
at all and it's all private information
these are people that are have degrees
okay this is law they can't
uh give away your information you don't
have to worry if that was the case then
i'd be
screwed do you understand better help is
something that i
i really find uh important they offer
video phone even live
chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone like i said on
camera
if you don't want to i like to be seen i
like people to see me
crying or upset but you don't have to
it's much much
much more affordable than in person
therapy
you're talking to someone in hollywood
i've gone to these sessions where you
pay an arm and a leg
and uh these guys can give you just the
same better you can start communicating
with your therapist in under 48 hours so
if you're going through something
get some help you know join the millions
of people who are seeing what therapy is
really about
it may or not be right for you at first
uh
it's worth looking into and you know if
you don't like your therapist
you get another one it's that easy they
will get you another therapist
because let's face it we are our
greatest asset
period this podcast is sponsored by
betterhelp and inside of you listeners
get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
inside that's betterhelp.com
inside help get some help
hey you know uh obviously we haven't
talked about the the elephant in the
room but walking dead obviously is the
biggest
one of the biggest things that ever hit
television it's uh i know i watched
through the first
uh five seasons and uh you know it was a
movie every week it felt like i was
watching a freaking movie
and that's how i explained it i'd say
it's like i love horror i'm a huge
horror fan as everyone knows
and i go i'd be a zombie for a day i
remember even i
actually read for something in it a
while back but i remember i just loved
that show and when your character
i will tell you this there's a couple of
characters on the show they're all
really good actors
but when your character came on there
was something just
i i could just smell your character
there's just there's something
just real about him just really grounded
and
get a little dirt you know a little
dirty and
i don't know i just really love i mean i
know a lot of people loved abraham
and yeah it was such a great character
to watch and
did you first of all when they when you
got this did they say hey this is just
for a recurring
and then all of a sudden this thing blew
up and you're like holy [ __ ] i i just
lasted a couple seasons here
how many seasons did you do four came in
the middle of four
uh season four and then did all of five
all of six
and then uh the beginning the end of
seven right right right so
you know in in walking dead math that's
actually three and a half seasons
because
even when you know there was twenty when
i was there there's 22 regulars
22 regulars over 16 episodes you would
do maybe
five or six episodes some years
um so my first year when i did four
even though i was get i was guessing uh
that
you know that's basically just shy
of what some people were doing ever you
know for a season that we're working
season so
um i was i was told when i met with
scott
pimple um i was told that they were
getting
back to the trying to get back closer to
the comics
um because they'd gone
really far in season three i guess and
you know with
with killing off some some major um
players who were actually still alive up
until recently in the comics
and uh so the idea and the feel of it
and everything behind it was that they
wanted to
get back to the comics but i knew in the
comics you know after doing the research
on that that he only
was around for you know
20 or 30 uh publications
um i used to know the numbers he came in
like uh
i forget what it was but i feel like he
was in it at 30
something and and died at
90 something um well you read all of
those you actually read all of them i
did i read i read up until
his uh reading until his passing and
then a little a little a little beyonce
gets really sucked into it
um and so i knew it was it was great you
know there was there was a bunch that
had changed from the
from the graphic novels to the the show
it's interesting that the
daryl character um
changed how a lot of the other
characters were dealt with because what
what kirkman had done
in the graphic novel was he would bring
in characters who would become
confidants with rick and sort of
sort of like his new best friend uh not
to sort of trivialize
that you know his writing but um but
that that's the
the the mechanism they served someone
who would get close to him
and we could learn more about him uh
through the people that he met you know
and it was
same thing with tyrese when he met
tyrese he very very close
shared a lot and through the sharing you
learned a lot about him that he got
killed off and that you know then my
character comes in
um so having the daryl character there
who is his true best friend and
confidant the whole time
changed the dynamic of how those those
characters when they did come in how
they functioned in the world so
um i knew that my time would be
sort of similar to what was in the comic
um it didn't really matter
you know fans loved it or hated it you
know kirkman said early on you know the
way we think that we show this world is
a dangerous world is we we kill people
we love
so you know i knew that i wasn't you
know
when did they tell you michael rick it
wasn't daryl you know it wasn't
that wasn't well what did they tell you
when did they didn't do a pull up
i interviewed this guy chris jericho a
big wrestler and he said
that he knew that he was gonna win the
championship that day they told him so
did they give you like a week a week
ahead they go hey
did they call you what was the real
scoop i got a call when i was in
uh in new york um
i think it was a break between between
we shoot our seasons in two parts the
first
first part in the second part there's a
week break in between sort of the
hottest time
in georgia the crew has already gone
through eight episodes
everybody's just dead it's brutal it's
august
um and so we take a week two weeks off
uh
in in august and uh
then we come back and finish the rest of
the season and during that time i
i ran out to new york
and i get a phone call from
uh from scott he's like hey uh he leaves
me a message hey
uh you're dead no i take it
the ad called the a d
matt goodwin called he's like hey uh
scott wants to set up a
uh a call with you for next week
okay did you say why i would have been
like who do you know he's like do you
know what it's about he's like no no
it's just uh
you know second see just sort of like
where everything's headed blah blah call
okay all right sure next wednesday
two o'clock sounds great so then i
immediately call scott i'm like hey
uh call me back
because i'm like hey what's going on i
go you can't do that
you can't be like oh hey i said if
you're going to kill me kill me i want
to know i don't want to be wondering
like i'd rather start processing me
being dead now then
then wonder if i'm going to be dead for
another week and a half
and then have to process it i said it
doesn't matter you're already like i
already assume i'm dead
so either confirm or deny and he said
well
i said okay so yeah so i'm dead well no
i mean i don't i don't yes
it's okay um so we talked about this
when i first came in i wasn't
uh i wasn't upset per se um
i wasn't happy to leave the show you
know i would have
liked to have continued if that was in
the cards
uh but i wasn't i wasn't really bummed
out about it because i knew it was
coming
so uh ultimately i i wish we had done a
few more episodes with myself and
suniqua
uh when you know when all-out war
happened because it would have been nice
to actually see
abraham functioning as a soldier um
but that wasn't in the cards and that's
you know we have to make room for
you know characters we love die so new
characters can come in that we can fall
in love with
yeah that's that's the rotation of the
show and i have
zero uh issue with that at all did you
cry
when you died no did the day when you
left everybody did you know emotions
uh the day no because it was really a
celebration but there were times when i
when i got sad knowing that i wasn't
like i might see events that everybody
was at it was sort of like oh
but i don't
i don't i don't know if i cried and i'm
a crier i'm a crier i'd tell you if i
cried
i [ __ ] cried mayonnaise commercials
i'm a john cryer i cried at mandalorian
last night i'm [ __ ] crying i i did
i'm with somebody and i literally turned
off the lights and like dude
what are you doing i go nothing are you
going to cry
for what did you watch queen's gambit oh
yeah
crystal when in the end when she's doing
the thing when she takes a deep breath
and she looks up and they all come down
from the ceiling
just weeping oh like a little baby ball
state university brother it was like it
was
i was like oh my gosh like the cavalry
came in you know it's like the same
feeling that you get
at the end of an action movie when
everybody shows up and you're like yes
tears for fears man they're not there
yeah dude i get so
i don't know what it is i get emotional
sometimes and i think i gotta call the
doctor i'm
i shouldn't be crying at this and then i
realize well you're just emotional
i don't cry constantly but all of a
sudden i look at my dog and i go
i might not have you i mean i know
you're two years old right now and you
got a long time but
no but like i have an older dog so i'm
always going oh my god i get
like emotional the thought of like my
best anyway we don't get into that but
so okay so you didn't you you might have
got emotional maybe a little bit but
like really you didn't get emotional but
um you know i heard something from
another
actor on the show a long time ago that
said you know and not knocking amc they
make great product but
they they used to hold you guys limited
to the amount of conventions you can do
is that true some some actors were when
they got brought
in uh after me
uh not not literally after me but
sometime after
i was hired that became part of the
negotiation
and and you got
you know a little bit more per episode
uh to not do
you know x number of episodes i mean i
mean at conventions
why i don't know that's so weird
i i know so i know some people were
um some people were doing them like
every weekend and it was interfering
with the work schedule oh
it wasn't the top you know the top top
people like norman
norman wasn't doing that you know uh he
was
his stuff was all scheduled out and
spaced out um
you know they took a lot out of him
because he was you know a huge huge
convention drop
so it you know it took a toll on him
just physically
um doing that so but there were some
some people who were
doing quite a bit and i think i think
again i don't know because it did
it didn't affect me what i was doing i
didn't do too many of them when we were
in season uh if i did i tried to
schedule them around as everyone does we
try to schedule more episodes we're not
in yeah right
right um but what was it like the first
time you went to a convention because
when you went to a convention it was
probably what was i mean i
i can imagine you went for other roles
but this had to be the biggest no you
didn't so you hadn't been to a
convention
and so the first time they say michael
cudlitz what was your response because i
guarantee there was 400 people in line
the first time they well maybe let's
back up even the first
convention ever i was at was new york
comic-con when my character was
introduced oh god
uh four thousand people
in was it javid chavis javascript jacob
javed center
jacob javits javits yeah and uh i say
four thousand i think that's
a little bit under but it's like
whatever that meant the main room holds
it's more than four thousand but i don't
know the exact number i know it's not
the
six almost seven thousand that's in san
diego
um they start talking about
we're gonna do a gag i'm basically gonna
go out there dressed as
uh just some cosplayer i got like a
cheap plastic cowboy hat and a
sport jacket and a
a white uh what's the
what's the face the white face with the
mustache
uh oh the uh v for vendetta no what is
it
yes yes something similar to that or
maybe it's even more just innocuous
right just a white like mask anyway so
i'm up there
and i have a microphone and they want me
to basically do this
iconic uh chunk of dialogue from the
from the uh from the graphic novel and
the microphone is right next to me where
everybody can ask group questions
so they say okay everybody come on up to
ask questions
i'm like right there and i just stand up
so i'm hiding with the microphone and
the thing and they're getting
they're talking about the show and
they're this and that blah blah blah and
they go on and i don't know i open up
the questions
and i stand up and uh i stand up
in front of the person they're like hey
what are you doing and i turn around i'm
like shut up
and they're like what and i talk like
hey
i'm like give start giving him [ __ ] i'm
like where's abraham
these people want to see where abraham
is you write the show right and robert
kirk was like look
i'm at some point i'm like you know what
shut up
give me an answer like i'm really
confrontational at this point i find
that later
on that andrew lincoln's wife was there
and she was like oh my god there's a
crazy man who's
gonna pull out a gun and open fire and
like it's gonna be some crazy
shut up so
yvette was monitoring hard work wasn't
moderating that time
uh and she's like i'm sorry i can't hear
you because of your mask
and you know you take your mask off i
was like
sure so i take up drop the helmet pull
off the thing
drop the jacket and i'm standing there
dressed as abraham
and the [ __ ] audience because you
know the people who go to the
conventions that's one breeda fan but
the fans said go to the conventions and
then wait in line for nine hours for the
panel
whole other level love them they know
love them they're committed
exactly what's going down they just
start going nuts
and i thought that was over and i was
like holy crap this is insane
and event's like you know why don't you
come on up here and just and say hi to
everybody
i'm walking up and i remember this is a
thing online everyone can check it out
there's a photo of me at new york
comic-con
i get the year uh i've been walking
across stage and i
walk up and i hold up a fist
uh or hold up to go to wave and uh
because they're all cheering everyone's
cheering and the minute i put my hand up
you know i'm thinking holy crap this is
insane i put my hand up
and the wall of sound that hit me
well i was literally speechless
i was literally what holy [ __ ] what the
hell that's a beautiful thing
what a beautiful i i couldn't even could
not wrap my head around it
that was my first convention experience
that is so and i'll tell you what
because i've had it with like small but
the the fans i i love them i mean the
the people
i'm a fan of shows that i think i'd go
bonkers i love conventions i was going
to conventions before
i even became famous at all and i was
like kind of that guy walking around and
so
when people love something it's such an
awesome thing to be a part of because
it's just a giant
family of people that can relate to one
thing if
not only one thing if if only one thing
and that's a beautiful thing when
everybody can go hey
like for this shitty uh year we had
everybody can go
ah we have this and that's something to
grasp
a hold of and i think that's awesome man
i think that's so awesome and i bet it
was
i could tell it's overwhelming because
you know it is it's just
for 4 000 or more people to just be
going we love you we're in we can't wait
you're like oh my god i already have
people that love me this is i can't wait
i've been waiting my whole life for this
yeah it's [ __ ] genius listen we're
gonna go real quick to uh [ __ ] talking
with michael cudlitz and this is just
rapid fire and this is uh
just fans on my patreon uh if you want
to join patreon patreon.com
inside of you here it is quick question
shane m what do you do to relax
or wind down michael whiskey and cigars
what kind of kind whiskey my go-to right
now
is woodford um
just when i got off this i got a lot in
my a lot of different whiskeys i'm a big
fan of the small batch local distillers
will you email me something that i
should have if i haven't really gotten
into whiskey because i grew up in
indiana
and i i drink like jack daniels jim beam
like whiskey or bourbon but
i don't know what a good like anything
you know what i'm used to
cheap like blanton's is a great well
just email me
i'll have you email me just what you
drink and i'll you know the cigar i
can't do it i'm not a man enough i i'll
choke to death
david cigar bar now in uh nashville you
have a cigar bar in nashville what's it
called
it's called the red phone booth wow
they're really chatting from
booth.com and we are partially open
all right guys check that out you have
to check that out dave p
i mean i didn't ask you this but were
you satisfied with your character's
death and walking dead
was i satisfied yeah yeah i mean those
are all water shoulda codas
um way way way better than the graphic
novel
um but yeah lisa h what was it like
working on beverly hills 90210 any fun
memories of being on set
uh it was great um actually uh
if i did not con you know move forward
with my career as an actor i would still
be doing construction for film and
television right now and
some of my closest friends are still
doing it i always love the feeling of
walking away at the end of the day and
there was a something there that
wasn't there in the morning um i also
started
acting on it i mean it wasn't my first
gig but i i did
uh twelve that one of doing twelve
episodes and uh
everything i sort of learned there
has helped me be what i am today as a
performer and an actor
i'm sorry the director um because i was
able to
see all sides of it uh and work with
some really wonderful people
awesome liam p which character that
you've portrayed do you identify
identify with most um i don't know
probably be a cross between
uh john cooper and denver southland
southland and band of brothers those two
roles yes all right
i dig uh last two questions claudine and
how did you find it going from playing
abraham to directing on the walking dead
was that uh you know what was that
transition
uh because they i had so much love from
the cast
and the crew was it was sort of seamless
um it was i felt incredibly supported
it was a wonderful wonderful experience
and i you know initially thought it was
like okay they're doing me a favor
because they like me and you know uh but
then when they asked me back i was like
all right
that would be a self-inflicted wound uh
if it didn't go well and uh
it did i loved it and uh i'm doing it
more i'm gonna be going back again this
year
awesome jerry w my wife and i are huge
walking dead fans
was the peace sign to sasha in your
final scene
an acting choice or scripted great
performances all the way through to the
end dude
uh we actually film the end that's an
interesting question because we filmed
the end of season
uh six uh
with
what was it it was it was my pov so it
was the victim's pov
and it was always following him
and then it looked then he got hit
whoever it was got hit and looked back
up and got hit again um
when they came back into season seven
they wanted some connection between me
and sasha
but they had already shown that whoever
was being hit never looked at her
so we were kind of locked into this
thing that i i couldn't
you know the perspective of who it was
couldn't look at her so that
that was something that um that i added
because it was something that we ran
through multiple times where we did the
peace sign to each other was kind of our
unspoken
deal and then i uh on the night of
shooting it
actually ran it by scott and greg i said
hey you know
even though i don't look at her if we
haven't shown
you know what she's looking at i said if
i'm looking straight ahead and i
shoot the peace sign down but we see
that she is seeing it
um that could be a great little easter
egg uh for the fans
this is really really low in frame too
it's like if you barely see it you know
it's not featured it's not like you know
ooh
close you know over the head with it as
it were
it was really wonderful and subtle and
they let me do it and
uh it's uh it was highly effective
awesome uh last question really i said
that but michael rosenbaum has a
question
how happy was your wife when you shaved
that mustache
very she was more happy when we were
able to stop doing the red dye
which we had to do a year after i died
because we were keeping it a secret
from the audience did she taste it could
she taste it when she kissed you the dye
or smell about the i don't know about
that but uh she could definitely feel
the
nastiness of all of that
did she did she want to kiss you less
because of that oh come on man look at
this
you want to kiss me less i love it dude
this has been
so fun i mean i know we didn't know each
other but i
i really enjoy this you're just a guy's
guy and uh you're just so humble and
sweet and thanks for opening up and and
just talking [ __ ] man i i really
appreciated this
absolutely thank you this is fun yeah
well maybe we'll do it again in a year
yeah we'll do it we'll do it uh we'll
we'll check back in once clarisse is a
huge hit yeah it will be
i guarantee people want to see that you
know whoever the
people who love it are going to really
love it i'll tell you that um
it's dark it's we've seen pieces of it
it's very much
very much like the movie uh it's very
it's also
has a little bit of a true detective
vibe to it has a little bit of a killing
it's not it's not your typical uh
cbs show um not a typical procedure
as a good thing because i i prefer the
stuff that's not on network
lately as most people are when does it
come out
february 11th february 11th so you're
quarantining right now and then you're
gonna go finish some more episodes
yep got uh seven more days in quarantine
oh man i love that what's your favorite
line of silence for the lambs the one
line you always remember
my favorite lion besides fava beans i
just like
whenever i hear when i hear clarice i
can hear clarisse
i hear him saying clarice every time you
hear the name of the show clarity
i think my favorite was uh when he goes
i don't think i'll kill you
not today it's far more interesting with
you in it yes the last line of the movie
right
and i like the line where he says what
did he say who
multiple migs in the next cell he said
something to you what did he say
and then i can't repeat what he said but
anyway hey thanks for allowing to be
inside of you man all my best to you and
the family and
and and health and happiness and keep up
the great work man thank you
and big hug to your grandma i will give
her a big hug for you
all right take care buddy see you
michael thanks man
i i found him fascinating what did you
like mostly about michael he just seemed
like a good
dude uh because i didn't i also didn't
know much about him but uh
and because he just he portrays the
tough guy very well
and great facial hair no i mean always
so it's always nice when uh
yeah someone who plays like a stone cold
badass on television
is just a genuinely nice human being
just a sweet man yeah yeah i felt like
it's comforting
it is comforting it's i you know again
when you can open up
as playing the tough guy and you know
you sometimes
you feel like they're the intangibles
they're untouchable they're
we don't know anything but oh he's tough
he's got his life under control he's got
but you you hear the hardships you hear
the things that you go through you hear
uh certain things and it uh humanizes
people yeah
and i think that's important so thank
you michael cudlitz again if you
enjoyed today's show please follow us on
the handles ryan
uh inside if you pod on twitter inside
of you podcast instagram facebook
youtube.com
inside of you with michael roosevelt
yeah please watch you watch these
wonderful videos on youtube and
all that and again the band uh our album
sunspin
the album is called best days it's on
itunes at amazon
you can follow us which i hope you will
if gosh if just a tenth of these people
just said okay you know what i'll follow
your handles at
sunspin band and uh we'll go to
sunspin.com
and check some stuff out if you want to
book the band or whatever
and uh just listen to the album tell us
what you thought and uh
you know as i said earlier we have a
little contest uh releasing the new
album
we're gonna do a contest where we give
out some goodies for free if you want to
learn more about it go follow us on our
social
at sunspin band and you can win some
stuff and maybe even a zoom with us
um so yeah bryce will take care of that
and we'll uh we'll
uh you'll go online and we'll figure it
out and uh
tell all your friends and my wonderful
patron family thank you again
i made a mistake ryan and i don't know
if it's a mistake but i sent uh
you know i have for certain tiers of the
uh
uh patreon i send merch boxes and i sign
a little note
um and every couple months they get a
box well i accidentally sent two i think
to most people
so what do you do i guess you got a free
box yeah
i mean you're already getting a box and
i get another box i don't know what else
to do
[ __ ] i can't just say okay well now
you're not getting your next box
i'm sure they'd understand but you know
i love them and if you want to join
patreon go to patreon p-a-t-r-e-o-n dot
com
inside of you um and become a patron
i'll message you after
i love the family we have you get
private youtube
lives just for the patrons there's
special discounts on merch at the inside
of you online store
there's uh there's just tons of stuff
and i uh message people back
and uh some people get to ask questions
to the guest [ __ ] talking with rosenbomb
or should talk in with michael cudlitz
or whatever
uh whatever you like um and then there's
the merch and
all the stuff you get a shout out in
fact i'm gonna give the shout outs now
these are the shout outs
for the top tiers for the uh patreon and
here we go
uh nancy d mary b leah s trisha f
sarah v little lisa yukiko jill e brian
h lauren g
see they're they're flowing right here
you see this yeah they stopped them now
right didn't you well no
they're frozen they're frozen and then
they will change when you reach the
bottom of the list
really so as i talk they go no they they
stay and then
when you hit a certain point when you
reach the bottom it changes to the next
one
lauren g brian h nico p robin asked
jerry w i wonder if it changed
just now i don't know robert i jason w
stephen j kristen k
amelia oh allison l jess j lucas m raj c
joshua d emily s cjp samantha m if i
sound tired today
it's because i am i'm a little tired i
woke up at three in the morning but
i still love you and maybe for the rest
of the names i should give a little more
emphasis jennifer n stacy l carly h
jen s janelle b carey b tabatha 272 not
to be confused with kevin 273 ashley
ryan kimberly e
mike e marissa and el don supremo dan
jack s slater love you ramirez love you
beth b
love ya everybody i love you santiago m
sarah f chad w
lee and p roshan roshan r rey a maya p
my asia
maddie s kendrick f ashley e shannon d
matt w belinda and kevin v
james r chris h i knew she w
osborne amy c dave h samantha s
spider-man chase shiloh g
ray h harada alyssa c
tabitha t misha h deb a tom and suzanne
b
henry s kdf we're almost done here
liliana a hi liliana we talked a few
times
michelle k what up marcus he can
hannah b michael s talia m
uh luke h john s andrew t christy s
claire m liz j laura l chad b
rachel or rochelle e nathan e brandon d
taylor k neil a marlon e meg k
janelle p also i just did i forgot to
mention i did a uh
batman beyond with kevin conroy uh an
old episode we did a table read for ign
that's gonna be coming out
later in the month nice and i read a
couple characters um
and it was a lot of fun we did it last
night and it was uh we had some
technical difficulties but they'll edit
it and it will sound good
uh thank you all for for listening thank
you all for supporting this podcast i
will continue to do it as long as you're
here listening or watching
and um from ryan and myself here in the
hills of hollywood
hollywood hills the hollywood hills the
home of
michael rosenbaum oh yeah baby uh
thank you for for coming around and
hanging out with me
and uh there's a camera right up there a
nice wave yeah and thank you for
allowing to be inside of each
and every one of you uh i know you're
not listening dad but maybe one day
you'll be like oh i'm listening
uh i love you all thank you very much
[Music]
all right